[Music]
Jesus I can feel my face getting boxed
in for hating this already it was a
nightmare so many dead people so many
victims and that was just pre-production
also narration it all started a few days
ago when I came here for a rave people
must really love acid if they're going
to an island for a rave also movie
started the story and then went straight
back to the opening credits this is one
of those rare movies we're seeing Clint
Howard's name in the opening credits
it's actually a relief movies only
tangible connection to its video game
origins are to run highly distorted
clips of said videogame behind the
opening credits so we're gonna miss
Gregg and Simon oh not you again
you got that looks and not much between
those ears Jesus is this whole movie
gonna be still shots over expositional
narration this is either a rave or an
invitation into a volcano call 50-50
chance but like I said these people
really love acid they missed the boat to
the rave this guys narrating about
missing a boat to a rave with us doing
it like he's Max Payne or something I
mean there are still people who need to
be credited in this movie also two
different people got story credit on
this thing
with all its narration and opening
credits movie did not include an
epilepsy warning because ii would
totally sponsor an illegal island rave
totally also movie that knew ahead of
time it could only afford fifty extras
still tries to pull off the massive raid
growl shots it's kind of cute actually
also who holds a rave in the middle of
the afternoon well duh you're on an
island in 2003 you shouldn't have even
had a call that lasted even one second
oh man they tried poor jörgen Prochnow
to this didn't they you know what they
call this island Isla de Muerta damn it
say hi to Jack Sparrow when you're there
assholes Brad oh so for $600 it's the
legendary island of the Dead you won't
go to but for a measly 400 more you're
willing to go that means you value your
lives at $400 Captain Kirk character
voices audiences incredulity no one will
be seated during the harrowing escape
from the Coast Guard scene if these cops
had wanted to stop the boat why didn't
they at least walk down the correct dock
how did Sega and the other Island rave
sponsors never once hear about the
islands curse legend if all the locals
know about it oh my god okay she's naked
discount Chris Evans crossed with Chris
Pine damn dude you were right next to
the side of the boat also face puking
bubbles under the water directly after
creepy in the woods stalker can leave
the viewer confused as to who and where
the actual evil really is there's
clearly nothing in the water but you
know what would have been awesome if
there was anything in the water
well she's topless so I have a boner but
she's washing puke out of her shirts so
oh no that actually doesn't affect my
boner well you are out in the open
washing your clothes topless so yes
zombie needs to assess the situation
before attacking a girl all by yourself
in the woods
why would Matt be in there door
base-jump scared
holy Sh matt is in the creepy house of
all the places on the giant ass for a
violin for him to go and for her to find
him instantly will wonders never cease
yep just like the video game Jesus how
far away is this island and why did The
Rave sponsors make the official dock the
farthest one away in the universe
you want me to radio for backup
yeah I think I can handle Viktor myself
there's pretty much no reason why you
didn't just catch up to him and handle
him already who was the mastermind
behind this party they had to go to the
island to scout the location first then
they had to come back and build the
stages and she and the monster just
waited because they knew more people
were coming I guess completely deserted
this girl is concerned about the raid
being empty but she wouldn't be if she'd
seen how few people were here to begin
with it's pretty easy for a crowd of
thirty to scatter over a few hours time
you puked on her face an hour ago how
was this possible yes unnecessary
suspense killing not clean Howard you
just killed the one name actor this
movie had going for it unless you count
that German dude from Das Boot whose
name I'm not even gonna try to pronounce
again or Smallville's Erica Durance but
that wasn't even her name back then she
changed it after being in this movie I
just don't take a pisses off the
depiction of men stupid and don't want
to get laid is probably the most
unrealistic thing about this movie 96%
of the dialogue in this movie is someone
calling out someone else's name okay
these candles simply have to have been
lit by the ravers who are long gone and
have surely been burning way longer than
they show before these horny asshole
teams show up death house herbs well he
coming am I going to myself the smart
one of the group wants to go into the
obvious death house this is after seeing
a bloody shirt and a general crime scene
five minutes ago hey let's be sure to
show the entire walk all the way to the
house shall we
hello what thought these were zombies
are some but turns out the evil killers
are just dudes and obvious terrible
Halloween masks go figure
discount Ethan Hawke these things came
and they attack the Wraith started
killing everybody everyone except the
guy with the camera who dutifully
continued to shoot while carnage
happened all around him they just kept
coming and coming and killing we finally
found this house we ran inside and tried
to hide that's when you guys came the
house that we've seen two people could
killed it but the monsters allowed these
guys to stay in unharmed for some reason
I thought you were more of them
whoo what this is actually a case where
someone isn't playing the pronoun game
and yet this guy asked what them means
even though he's seen a video of a bunch
of creatures attacking the party no
camcorder from 2005 could record this
much footage and still have a full
battery Sal says let's get the hell out
of here referring to yourself in the
third person while also referencing a
children's game that's a sinan bull
let's split up plot point pays off and
allowing the movie to bloat its runtime
by having the same assholes then need to
find the very people they split up from
the boat being named Lazarus in a movie
about the Living Dead is literally the
most clever thing this film has to offer
hold on zombies can swim more happens
during this videogame transition than
actually happened in the last scene here
hold this self-defense weapon while I
open a porta potti that possibly
contains a zombie or sin dude did you
not hear all the mobsters go attack the
tent or Cindy screams right after you
left
you were right next to them zombie Cindy
waited until they were looking forward
to come out and start killing people
well it's a damn good thing it only took
15 hours for this Coast Guard chick to
finally show up somewhere meaningful on
the island what the hell was that thing
not anymore
what the hell is or what's that thing he
or she is or was our blank blank not any
more cliche this guy seems to be taking
the recent zombification of his
girlfriend and her subsequent brutal
death rather well I suppose he's still
steaming about the poopy shirt though
hey shouldn't Easter clear that torch
with all that methane on his clothes
maybe I can get some answers by talking
to a person on the radio who was not
remotely here for that anyone have a
cellphone yeah we already tried it's not
working there's some sort of
interference and also probably the lack
of cell towers especially around death
Islands and especially since it's 2015 3
zombies are still taking their
recreational swim before attacking
Kirk's boat finally zombies are easy to
kill how come the zombies don't ever
attack while this movable feast is
underway moving through the forest
emotions Compson whatever the fuck part
of America this is supposed to be have
some lousy ass trigger discipline and
tribal make up white face with red
stitches normal ass looking teenage
girls this movies zombies can be
anything why were you using the handgun
in the first place tetanus
[Applause]
after one attack on the bridge and the
whole movies worth of teasing suddenly
read music and a zombie chase things
zombies not excitement I mean in none of
these shots is there ever a zombie and a
human in the same frame so why is
everyone running nope that gun was out
of bullets remember it doesn't magically
reload when you're holster the thing
week the asian girl in the American flag
spandex is named Liberty what do you
think I'm trying to do you fucking moron
well you are taking forever trying to
shoot this one zombie wait just a
goddamn minute and when did this random
rave teenager girl become Jackie Chan
with the kicking and such I guess I
might do the same thing after fighting a
bunch of zombies but what a dumb ass
right why not just get on Kirk's boat
right now I don't know too many good law
enforcement officers who would take a
civilian with them on a dangerous trek
through zombie territory but that's just
me I don't know anyone who's seen a
zombie movie might call them zombies and
zombie movies clearly exist in your
world because the one guy was talking
about Romero earlier these are zombies
pure and simple and don't tell me you
were trying to figure out what those
things were 20 seconds ago like you had
no idea and then suddenly come to the
conclusion that zombies is the right
answer with no problem like The Walking
Dead roll crit oh wait no you suck way
too much for that
that's all right from this story goes oh
great I'm black and white flashback this
is ambien movie has a centuries-old
origin story this but just said he had
no idea what those things were then
launches into a story explaining exactly
what those things were some say so does
so were we when did this guy get a
weapons harness the Marine Patrol woman
gave him a gun and she didn't have
anything else to give him so where the
hell did that come from you
much like the nazgûl in Fellowship of
the Ring this zombie smells something
right under its nose but to science
there's no way this dude is directly
beneath me this guy's whole role is
absorbing stuff behind trees but the
zombies in the water are dead right and
even if they aren't isn't that better
than staying here we don't know it's
it's on that boat
give me a fuckin break the amount of
stupid in this group rivals the
characters and saw two for sheer lack of
brainpower on all the zombies are dead
in the boat area if there's one that
decided to highlight for some dumb
reason then you have an axe dude
house it's the exact same danger that
you're worried about concerning the boat
by running back into the woods to find a
house but sure sounds like a amazing
plan fortunately this dickhead only
smuggled cigars and highly convenient
weapons look a machete is great but in
this situation it's not the best does
the boat still not sound like a better
idea especially now you have a lot of
weapons shouldn't they already be
looking for you it's been like a lot of
hours since you were able to report I'm
serious about killing zombies now I put
my hair in a ponytail for this I guess
the greater population of zombies on
this island we're waiting for the
movie's finale to show up in a large
crowd instead of the lesser handfuls of
them that we've been seeing for this
whole movie bunch of amateurs not only
don't all shoot each other but also
become crack shots in time of zombie
crisis meaningless series of 360 shots
um this girl goes from two handguns to a
single shotgun in the next shot these
assholes in the background are clearly
doing nothing this guy right here just
runs past a tasty human and lets her
pull out a grenade that grenade didn't
even kill anything
zombie conga line first off you're
jumping right into the axe Pat of this
slow-motion shot second off how does
jumping improve your shooting skills
third the axe Falls harmlessly as if
she's Neal from the matrix running out
of ammo was a problem before almost ten
full minutes of full obvious safe place
to bury an axe in the stunt guys chest
is obvious so many of these zombies have
no clue why they're here some of them
are even going in different directions I
feel like with a sheer number of zombies
they should have already been taken by
that also look at this chick she's just
standing here watching this and
apparently has a betting pool with the
other zombies who aren't doing jack she
either there was only a way someone
could shoot these zombies I'll shoot
this zombie but I'll be damned if I
shoot zombies attacking my girlfriend
the store blockade crab actually works
yeah man light that one candle that
should help oh yeah caring for zombie
wounds just got a whole lot sexier needs
your help unreasonable anger who can be
able to look me in the eyes with a face
like this and I still think you're
pretty damn sexy arbitrary romance
yeah it's almost too quiet this is one
of the lines airplane made fun of way
back in 1980 it's so cliche it's 23
years passed already being made fun of
in another movie yeah what he said she's
dead I didn't save her it's not your
fault how the fuck do you know
you just asked what happened three
seconds ago you don't know she played E
and the power of boners really is
stronger than like anything also there's
a dead body with no legs directly
underneath you it's Kirk he needs to
take a look at him he's getting worse
you mean you took time out from
frenching that one guy to check on Kirk
horniness trumps all other things like
the man you resume making out right now
no the Spanish prisoner who founded this
Zombie Island most definitely took time
to write a book on how to kill zombies
on this island well actually more points
if the book has a chapter that says you
should have gone to the boat bitch and
according to the officers logs it says
the Castillo sir mono killed the captain
then beach the ship and lit it on fire
huh I wonder how the officer continued
making along of everything that was
happening after the captain was killed
and the boat was set on fire okay here
on this island full of flesh-eating
zombies take a look at this cliche it's
not human now so now you're a crack shot
and a microbiologist Jesus it's
completely unnatural it's continuous
hunt geez what a dumbass I highly doubt
that this dude was whistling that
particular sound a minute ago
if your zombie and all you think about
is death where do you come up with a
spirit to whistle like that if there was
ever a time for casual conversation this
is it what were these assholes waiting
for boys you couldn't just run to a
safer place to light this dynamite now
you're gonna blow the door which is what
you didn't want to do earlier when you
were trying to get into this place one
ping stick of dynamite 20 feet away from
the porch somehow blows out the windows
and the front door why would you do this
well this movies already thrown the door
blockade rule bug out the window but a
shovel in keeping the zombies out guys
Simon does nothing for no reason so the
zombies can grab him how is Rudy leading
this charge the women went before him
down the trapdoor did he just push them
aside to get into the lead if so what a
dick
dive jumping to safety near an explosion
cliche also all the zombies that were
outside a minute ago must have gotten
warning about the house before it
exploded dude no one who has watched
this movie this far still needs
reminders about its videogame origins
this is the only part remotely like the
game but it's silly how all of them keep
coming from the front and none of them
wait until they pass by to jump out most
monsters will follow you anywhere a guy
we thought was dead and is acting weird
and is probably evil now wait did the
zombie master set up this elaborate trap
for them knowing for a fact that they
would find the trapdoor in the house why
didn't they just come through the
tunnels and kill them while they were in
the house didn't you just say exactly
why he did it in your question geez what
happened here these zombies are massive
cups meanwhile this barn was just
sitting out here near the zombie
graveyard not one zombie could open the
door or be linin by the main bad guy
during the entire time they were in this
house hey let's in this zombie movie
with a spinny sword fight what do you
think that's so crazy it just might work
immortal guy is totally oblivious to
Rudy running right towards him with an
axe boob power emergency boob power
deactivated this a n-s response
helicopter took o 80 hours to respond
she okay she got stabbed in the sternum
and yet actually yeah she is pretty much
still fine Kurian oh so that's why he
thought the blood thing was ingenious
he's the main bad guy doctor from the
video game well I don't know about you
but I survived a zombie invasion I want
to continue the work that was
responsible for that invasion and now we
go home
me and Alicia whenever she is new
whatever I've created
oh come on you applied the zombie
medicine to Alicia how's that working
out movie over anyway
I guess I'll just live my life after
this without knowing what the hell just
happened also explained to me how he's
narrating this by himself at the
beginning of the movie when he's with
Alicia and immediately goes to the
helicopter at the end of the movie
[Music]
so I can't bring myself to regret the
decision to leave home have another beer
this will make you feel better you're
welcome the cause of and solution to all
of life's problems
not not snotty no country I have heard
of this be English not not safe not
again I dare you I double dare you
mother go since not one more goddamn
time
Wow you get a load of that what the hell
is it
it's laser fencing it's high voltage on
the perimeter the whole building says go
away